Speaker 1: Failed former President Donald Trump
in one of his most cartoonishly bizarre acts gave,
I guess you would call it a eulogy at the
funeral service of Diamond, of Diamond and Silk.
Her real name was not Diamond. It was anything.
Lynnette Hardaway. She passed away not long ago,
believed to be from COVID unvaccinated. We'll
get to that, by the way, a little bit later,
Donald Trump announced in a soaking wet and
slurring statement as we looked at earlier,
that he would be presiding over it. Donald Trump
did not know that this was going to go for 3 hours
and in fact, he ended up complaining about
it. But let's start with Trump's heartwarming
and emotional tribute to Diamond, saying the
prisons of many countries are emptying out into
the United States. The mental institutions of
many countries are emptying out into the United
States. Talk about gas prices and inflation.
Not a typical eulogy, as one would expect.
Speaker 2: That, you know, things we can
fix, inflation, we can fix so much of what's
been damaged over the last two years. We had it
going so well, but we can fix these things. But,
you know, millions of people, I think 15 million
people, they say three, maybe four. I now know I.
Speaker 1: Remember a memorial service
remembering the great diamond. This
is what Trump is talking about.
Speaker 2: They have no idea how
many people and they allowed their prisons to be
emptied out into the United States of America.
They allowed their mental institutions to go
after them into the United States of America.
Speaker 1: Never happened.
Speaker 2: Common sense would
tell you that if you had common sense, you
wouldn't be doing that. Mike would know that,
but you wouldn't be doing this.
Speaker 1: By the way,
Trump's pointing to Mike Pillow.
Speaker 2: Millions and millions of people are
coming and no country would be able to withstand
this. No culture, whether you're rich or poor. And
we're not really rich, we owe, as of this morning,
$31 trillion. Right? So I don't know. You call it
rich, I guess. I don't know. Maybe not.
Speaker 1: This is really helping me to
mourn and grieve with the Diamond's family.
Speaker 2: We spend a lot of money on other
countries, and many of those countries hate us and
we give them money. So common sense would tell you
all of these things. Inflation was caused by
energy. They stopped the energy and all of a
sudden you gasoline went from a dollar 87 a gallon
to five, six, seven, California, $8 a gallon.
And when your baker makes his cakes
and when your hospitals create heat
and all of the different things you need
this for, everything goes up and it's run
away. It's far greater than people thought.
Speaker 1: This this is this is performance
art. I mean, in a thousand years when future
sociologists and anthropologists and psychologists
want to learn about the insanity of this era, you
would show them this and you would say this was a
funeral eulogy for a woman who died and died at
a relatively young age. And this was a former
president who showed up and talked about mental
institutions, so-called being emptied out into our
country. Trump then complained, as he often does,
he was not expecting this to go more than 3 hours.
Okay. And he was not particularly happy.
Speaker 2: And I don't believe you know,
they told me. So give me a little time because
I have a lot of people waiting for me back in
a place called Palm Beach, Florida. They
said, give me a little time. What do you
think it'll take that 15, 20 minutes in and
out? I said, Well, it could take longer. He's
a little longer than 15 minutes, right? Oh.
Speaker 1: Yes, it was. I mean, it is true.
It was three plus hours of stories and prayers
and hymns. Is that how you pronounce it? Hymns,
the new silent. And it took a very, very long
time. And. Donald Trump was not particularly
pleased with that. Donald Trump also announcing
to the crowd again, this is all in memory of
Diamond. It's all out of respect for her memory
and her life and everything. Trump announcing
he wanted to ensure that there would be valet
parking at their valet service at this event.
Speaker 2: Please know that we share in
your grief. That's why you have such an
incredible crowd of people. I said, Let's
pick a big place. I don't care. Don't worry
about it. Just pick a big place because.
Speaker 1: Trump's not paying anyway,
so who cares, right? He'll just not pay.
Speaker 2: Apple wouldn't have held the
kind of people, the number of people
that we have, and we're doing it right,
and that's the way it should be. And I did notice
a big line of very, very nice vehicles outside
that's going to be handled properly. Right. So
we're going to handle it properly, go out in
style. She knew that. Go out of style, folks.
Speaker 1: We will be remembering the life and
times of diamond and we will share in the grief
and and tragedy with her family. And a valet will
be properly handling all cars. Please make
sure to tip make sure to tip the valet. And
then just when you thought the eulogy could not
get any stranger, Trump decides to make it about
himself. And with tears and tissues in the crowd,
he concludes this moving tribute by reminding the
crowd that the 2020 election was stolen from him.
Speaker 2: How do we stop the cheating? How do we
stop it where you get more votes but you still
win? And the answer is the Republicans have to
get tougher. Yeah, the top people have to get
tougher. Right. And and you have to really
swamp them. There's a level at which even they
can't produce. And so if you win big enough,
you're going to get there. And then once we're
there, we're going to straighten it all out and
get it back to where it was.
Speaker 1: But yeah,
Saturday Night Live could do nothing with
this because this is already like part 20
of a Saturday Night Live skit. Unbelievable.
Unbelievable. It's it's a sort of genius parody,
avant garde performance art of some
way. It's Kafkaesque, it's delusional,
it's hilarious. It's sad. It's a tragic
comedy. Unbelievable. And listen,
Trump deserves some credit in the sense that
it was hard to imagine even Trump turning this
event into something so absurd and an unable
to be parodied. But he was able to do it.